and now here is my secret
a very simple secret
it is only with the heart
that one can see rightly
what is essential is invisible to the
eye
love does not consist of gazing at each
other
but looking outward together
in the same direction
all grown-ups were once children
but only a few of them remember it
it is the time you have wasted for your
rose
that makes your rose so important
perfection is achieved not when there is
nothing more to add
but when there is nothing left to take
away
what makes the desert beautiful
is that somewhere it hides a well
the most beautiful things in the world
cannot be seen or touched
they are felt with the heart
well
i must endure the presence of a few
caterpillars
if i wish to become acquainted with the
butterflies
you see
one loves the sunset
when one is so sad
you become responsible forever
for what you have tamed
i shall look at you
out of the corner of my eye
and you will say nothing
words are the source of
misunderstandings
if you love a flower that lives on a
star
it is sweet to look at the sky at night
all the stars are a bloom with flowers
a goal without a plan
is just a wish
you're beautiful
but you're empty
no one could die for you
true love begins when nothing is looked
for in return
a rock pile ceases to be a rock pile the
moment a single man contemplates it
bearing within him the image of a
cathedral
when someone blushes
doesn't that mean
yes
i am who i am
and i have the need to be
what saves a man
is to take a step
then another step
tell me who admires and loves you
and i will tell you who you are
but the conceited man did not hear him
conceited people
never hear anything but praise
the only thing you learn
are the things you tame
the time for action is now
it's never too late
to do something
a single event can awaken within us a
stranger totally unknown to us
to live
is to be slowly born
it is much more difficult to judge
oneself
than to judge others
the thing that is important
is the thing that is not seen
in every crowd are certain persons who
seem just like the rest
yet they bear amazing messages
no individual is isolated
he who is sad
saddens others
he who must travel happily
must travel light
i know but one freedom
and that is the freedom of the mind
sometimes
there is no harm in putting off a piece
of work
until another day
no one is ever satisfied where he is
only the children know what they're
looking for
we don't ask to be eternal beings
we only ask that things do not lose all
their meaning
sorrow is one of the vibrations
that prove the fact of living
no one appreciates the person which
they see too often
nobody appreciates what they have a lot
of
pure logic is the ruin of the spirit
a civilization is built on what is
required of men
not on that which is provided for them
straight ahead
you can't go very far
the shortest way to a person's heart
is sincerity
he who has gone
so we
but cherish his memory
abides with us
more potent
nay more present
than the living man
grown-ups are certainly very strange
the arms of love encompass you with your
present
your past
your future
the arms of love
gather you together
grown-ups never understand anything by
themselves
and it is tiresome for children to be
always and forever explaining things to
them
i have lived a great deal among
grown-ups
i have seen them intimately
close at hand
and that hasn't much improved my opinion
of them
but if you come at just any time
i shall never know at what hour my heart
is to be ready to greet you
and when your sorrow is comforted
you will be content that you have known
me
to forget a friend is sad
not everyone has a friend
thirst had made me a little feverish
and i looked at them as if i were in a
dream
if you succeed in judging yourself
rightly
then you are indeed a man of true wisdom
even though human life may be the most
precious thing on earth
we always behave as if there were
something of higher value than human
life
trying to be witty
leads to lying
more or less
i did not know how to reach him
how to catch up with him
the land of tears is so mysterious
he fell as gently as a tree falls
there was not even any sound
you don't need to appreciate your
parents
because they gave birth to you
appreciate the fact that they raised you
and raised you with dignity
only those sleep soundly in old age
who have a clear conscience
don't make friends after 60
because it can end sadly